so before 1920
children young people who were diagnosed
with type 1 diabetes
had only days weeks months to live
and very famous clinicians like
dr jocelyn in the united states found
ways to make these people live a little
longer
a few months sometimes a few years
by treating them with harsh diets
avoiding
carbohydrate intake for instance they
were called ketogenic diets
and by doing that people survived they
didn't
really live they just survived they lost
all their weight all their muscle
all their fat tissue and so it was
really a
very very grim prognosis before the
discovery of insulin
in 1921 it was like different things
came together
in a very lucky way with on the one hand
an orthopedic surgeon returning from the
war
frederick banting who wanted to do
research
who contacted professor mcleod at the
university of toronto
interested in physiology and so mcleod
gave
banting some lab space and also
allocated a student to him
charles best and he asked him to work on
these
pancreatic extracts they started working
on dogs
and what they showed is indeed that if
they
made extracts from pancreases they could
treat
pancreatectomized dogs and keep them
alive however their extracts were
impure and that is where everything came
together when they met
dr kolip who was a pharmacist
who was able to develop a method to make
purified extracts this time not from
dogs
but from cow pancreases from the
slaughter house
and so it was at the end of 1921
that kolip was certain that his
extract was pure enough to allow
experiments in humans
and so it was on the 10th of january
1922 that
a young boy leonard thompson who was a
14 year old child
dying from diabetes was treated with
insulin
for the first time in a toronto hospital
very soon the university of toronto also
realized that they couldn't
really manufacture um the the amounts of
insulin that were needed to to treat all
the people
living with diabetes and desperate to
get their hands on this miracle drug
and so they started to collaborate with
um industry like the conaut laboratories
and then
soon after with other bigger
pharmaceutical companies not only in
north america
but also very soon in
europe very soon people started
altering the nature of the insulin they
were using to treat
patients with diabetes the first thing
they tried was to
make the need for injections of insulin
every four to six hours
less and so they tried to make the
insulin longer
acting and some of my colleagues call
that
the dark ages of insulin treatment in
people with diabetes because
treating them only with a very
long-acting
insulin took us even further
from the physiology of what a beta cell
makes
as an insulin profile and so in the 40s
50s 60s
70s people being treated with just one
or two injections of insulin per day
meant that their glucose levels were not
well controlled
at all and so what we discovered is that
bad glucose control
led to severe long-term complications
of diabetes like blindness like kidney
failure
and heart problems
the hunt for manufacturing
different types of insulin purer
insulin less immunogenic insulin
was really aided by the whole genetic
engineering of bacteria and yeast
and therefore these new analogues that
we're now using
is really the fruit of all of that
discovery
the exciting bit about the celebration
of insulin is that the party is not
over yet indeed we are still discovering
new forms of insulin we're now at the
um beginning of being able to
use oral insulin we're seeing
um glucose sensitive acting
insulins we're seeing liver preferred
insulin so
research on insulin is extremely active
but honestly i hope we can stop
researching insulin quite soon and that
we may
find better ways to treat people with
type 2 diabetes
and that we can finally prevent and cure
type 1 diabetes
you